[Music]
on this Tuesday night we take you inside
the ICU the enemy is invisible the risk
life and death what it's like on the
front lines of kovat 19 it's really a
very smart fliers plus candid comments
about long-term care homes from a woman
who works in one they don't receive
proper care right now new details on the
Nova Scotia mass murder what the RCMP
are revealing first fires now floods
disaster and heartache hit Fort McMurray
Alberta again which I do plus impersonal
imperfect and unparalleled term service
the perils of virtual Parliament
[Music]
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with an update on where we're
at in this country on flattening the
curve and slowing the spread of kovat 19
new federal modeling shows all the
restrictions we are under are working
the number of confirmed cases is now
doubling every 16 days back in March
cases were doubling every three to five
days but the original models
underestimated the number of deaths it
is now projected more than 3,800
Canadians could die by May the fifth the
vast majority of deaths so far 79
percent are connected to long-term care
facilities the bulk of those are in
Ontario and Quebec which have 80 percent
of confirmed cases in Canada so there
has been progress and it is because of
the public health restrictions some
provinces are relaxing them but dr.
Theresa Tam said again today it must
happen slowly and be monitored or cases
could begin to rise again I would love
to build to tell Canadians that life
will be back to exactly where we were in
December 2 of last year but now public
health authorities will be easing things
very gradually but we talk about sort of
living with the virus for a significant
number of months and until there's
enough level of immunity
the whole point of flattening the curve
is to keep our hospitals from being
overwhelmed like they were in Italy and
New York City that has not happened in
Canada about 17 percent of people with
kovat 19 have ended up in the hospital
here about five percent in intensive
care then doctors and nurses fight an
enemy they can't see and still don't
fully understand
Global's Jeff's simple was granted rare
access to an ICU in Toronto each time
that door opens staff at Toronto's
Humber River Hospital hold their breath
concerned not only for their patients
but for themselves people are worried
about getting sick and they're worried
about bringing home to their families
and over the past six weeks they've seen
firsthand what kovat 19 can do never
really faced anything like this before
the ambulance arrives with another
suspected case a young man with
shortness of breath this hospital is now
treating around 60 kovat 19 patients of
all ages ray gentle is 55 this is no
joke the father of three has been
hospitalized for over a week his family
isn't allowed to visit only video chats
with his boys he was feeling sick at
home for days and suddenly found himself
gasping I tried to walk
I stood up shortage of breaths my lungs
were collapsed like on me this is quite
consistent it's actually quite scary dr.
Jaime Spiegelman says kovat 19 continues
to confound but he has noticed a pattern
in some of the sickest so this is her
x-ray initially they suffer flu-like
symptoms for up to 10 days before their
lungs rapidly fill with fluid you can
see that the air spaces these are
fluffiness that we're seeing as
significantly more on today's x-ray then
even two days ago so it's really a very
smart virus because it gives the virus
gives itself nine days to be able to be
content
just other people before a person gets
really really sick I can use that and to
save the really sick doctors perform a
high-risk procedure the team is
preparing to intubate
a 62 year old woman who just arrived
struggling to breathe before the cold if
someone has to be intubated we'd all you
know we put on a mask but we'd really
all kind of rush into the room now we
have to do things a lot differently for
their own safety they've redrawn the
PlayBook deploying extra layers of
protective gear and fewer staff inside
the room others stand watch outside in
case anything goes wrong and this time
it did the ventilator tube wouldn't fit
into the patient's airway her oxygen
levels plummeted and for a few moments
her heart stopped more staff and
equipment were rushed in
the doctors performed chest compressions
and in the end saved her life all you
want to do is help these people but in
our patients but just watching them
desaturate so quickly and not being able
to do everything that we can all the
time to help them is it is really
frustrating the patient remains in
critical condition but hospital staff
have given her and others a fighting
chance they're done for the day and will
be back here again tomorrow
you might have noticed that one of the
doctors we met in the emergency ward has
a familiar last name dr. Susan Tory is
the daughter of John Tory the Mayor of
Toronto who these days is also an
anxious father and grandfather we'll
bring you an intimate look at a family
on the front lines of this crisis coming
up this Sunday on our special program
the new reality
Donna looking forward to that Jeff's
simple in Toronto thank you and you can
watch coronavirus the new reality every
Sunday at 7:00 right here on global we
are tracking the numbers closely tonight
as Canada hits another milestone there
are now more than 50,000 confirmed cases
of kovat 19 across the country more than
2,800 people have died so far today more
than 1500 new cases have been confirmed
most of them are in Ontario and Quebec
in Atlantic Canada there have been no
new cases in New Brunswick for example
for more than a week Newfoundland and
Labrador has reported just two new cases
in the last week those numbers are
assigned physical distancing is working
but it doesn't mean the virus is gone
just that we have to learn to live with
it Eric Sorenson takes us through the
latest federal projections the spread of
the corona virus is slowing in Canada
and with that growing anticipation the
country is edging towards opening up the
economy the epidemic here has slowed
relative to many countries cases
doubling just every 16 days now and
across the country there are essentially
regional epidemics the curve has
flattened for several small provinces
and the growth has leveled off even in
Quebec and Ontario health officials now
looking at measures to ease restrictions
when the time is right for each
jurisdiction what some of those initial
measures could be in terms of easing
back some of those public health
measures the message has shifted from
ominous three weeks ago we're at a fork
in the road between the best and the
worst possible outcomes too cautiously
optimistic today you already know that
if your neighborhood doesn't have new
cases if your province is flattening the
curve this is a good sign
Canada is gradually containing the
epidemic weeks ago each infected
Canadian was infecting at least two
other people that was exponential growth
that number has now been brought down to
just over one other person and if you
can bring it below one the epidemic will
die out now we're familiar with modeling
scenarios in a worst case massive
infections with some controls it's a
little bit better and with the controls
we've taken isolation and distancing
we're within a curve with far fewer
cases but don't expect that curve to
flatten out entirely what with getting
back to somewhat normal life you can
expect to see some waves in the fall and
possibly the winter it's not that after
the first wave or we're in the clear
we're anticipating a second third who
knows how many waves but we're trying to
find a manageable level in terms of as
you say opening up the economy
it also means vulnerable populations
older and in group settings will
continue to be at risk
where ages are available Canadians over
60 account for 95% of kovat 19 deaths so
provinces have to be prepared to pull
back again if necessary for now we're
not through the first wave Ottawa's
model suggests by this time next week an
additional 500 to 1,100 Canadians will
have died from Cova 19 Eric Sorensen
Global News Toronto the Premier of
Quebec the province with the most cases
and the most deaths from kovat 19 says
there will be no immediate return to
normal life but Francois Lugo
did outline more plans today for gradual
relaxing of restrictions on May 4th
stores outside Montreal with an outdoor
entrance will be allowed to reopen not
shopping malls though on May 11th that
will apply to stores in the Greater
Montreal area manufacturers with 50
employees or less can restart May 11th
along with the construction industry but
strict Public Health rules and physical
distancing will remain in a big hit to
local news post media has announced it
is shutting down 15 local newspapers
because of the financial fallout from
kovat 19 the community papers are all in
Ontario and Manitoba about 30 people
will lose their jobs the company is also
laying off 50 people from its sales
units Post Media says it's taken a
significant hit from the loss of print
and digital ad revenue during the
pandemic executives and managers are
also taking pay cuts you can get a full
list of the affected publications on our
web site global news dot CA / global
national now to Nova Scotia the RCMP
there provided more details about the
mass murder of 22 people including a
clear timeline of the gunman's movements
and there's surveillance footage which
shows he stayed in an industrial area
overnight before carrying on with more
murders in the morning it's of great
interest to us what the suspect or the
government had done and had done at that
location but we do know that he spent
the evening there we've searched that
area thoroughly but we are making a plea
to anyone in that area if they had seen
anything suspicious
- please contact the police Global Sarah
Richey is with me from Halifax Sarah
what more did we learn from the RCMP
today yeah these new surveillance images
Donna really show us fill in some of the
gaps of the timeline that RCMP had
released last week and what the gunman
was doing on Saturday night and into
Sunday morning
it really helps underscore just how
quickly he was moving we know for
instance the first 911 for Tepic came in
just after 10:00 p.m. on Saturday police
arrived there at 1026 and it's just nine
minutes later that a witness says they
saw that mock RCMP Cruiser leaving the
area through a field
so we know there wasn't a lot of time
there the gunman in all of that had
managed to kill 13 people and light
three structures on fire before slipping
away by 11 o'clock the gunman is 25
kilometers away in the community of des
Burt we know he spent the night they're
not leaving until 5:30 the next morning
we also learned from RCMP today he had
several semi-automatic handguns and two
semi-automatic rifles they're still
working to determine where those came
from and when they were used the
investigation really nowhere near
complete they're halfway through
interviewing 435 different witnesses
they say the gunman's former partner who
managed to survive all of this will
continue to be a key witness as they try
to piece it together
Donna Sarah Richey and Halifax thanks
know province-wide emergency alert was
issued warning Nova Scotians a gunman
was on the loose
the RCMP relied on tweets to communicate
with the public
tonight Global News has learned there is
no national policy for when emergency
alerts should be issued even in the case
of an active shooter in an email to
Global News the RCMP said there is
currently no national RCMP policy on the
use of the national alert ready system
and the RCMP is looking into developing
a national operational policy as a
result of recent events in Nova Scotia
Fort McMurray battered again coming up
flood waters swamp in the community just
four years after those massive fires
coping with this new reality is tough
enough now people in Fort McMurray
Alberta are dealing with the worst
flooding in more than a century
thousands of people there have been
forced to flee their homes and is
heather Urich's west reports many of
them lost everything in the wildfires
four years ago for Brian Jean this has
been a sickening feeling of deja vu this
flood is much like the fire most of my
family in waterways have lost their home
Jean a former Alberta politician lost
his helps during the 2016 wildfire now
like so many others in the community
he's facing the thought of losing
everything again there are literally
have watered down I own the bracer was
as many as 12,000 people have been
forced from their homes because of
rising water the spring break up causing
ice jams and the timing could not be
worse
the combination of dealing with
evacuations alongside Kovach 19 is one
that's been discussed for several months
evacuation centers are drive-through
only crowded shelters are out of the
question this evacuation is happening at
a time when people are already hurting
financially we know that a flooding
event during Cova 19 response is having
exceptional impacts on people
local accommodations filled quickly
evacuees had to be sent to neighboring
communities even oil sands work camps up
north I'm hoping that this time around
it isn't gonna last as long as it last
time
Alberta's premiere toward the flood site
Monday pledging to support the area in
any way necessary Canada's military
could be asked to help as well though a
formal request has not yet been made for
a community that's been through so much
already it's a lot to take in but Jean
says he has the gift of perspective he
lost a son a year before the 2016 blaze
you can't replace these things you can
replace Heather Europe's West Global
News Calgary Canada is prioritizing
ahead the highlights and hiccups from
Canada's first virtual session of
parliament
Canadians are used to drama on
Parliament Hill but we've never seen
Parliament quite like this MPs took part
in an historic virtual House of Commons
session today and they discovered like
the rest of us that moving meetings
online can lead to a new set of hiccups
Abigail Beeman explains the Honorable
Minister of Health's is hi Duke please
unclick your mute problems familiar to
anyone who's braved a big group chat too
dark too close mr. speaker I'm not
hearing any sound and that pesky mute
button you turned off your muted again
not even the top boss is immunity
Minister I've switched my language to
English but this was a feat never before
attempted getting hundreds of MPs up and
running virtually with translation
having a public meeting on zoom' is not
a huge concern I'm much more concerned
about what's happening with classified
information and whether that's being
encrypted properly and for the most part
it worked
can the Prime Minister explain why
Health Canada has yet as has to this
point been unable to implement a
fast-track process opposition MPs trying
to hold the government accountable but
with no heckling and less drama than in
the House almost strange to watch the
Official Opposition Leader take on the
Prime Minister one on one screen to
screen we've seen around the world
problems with test gifts that have been
faulty or unreliable of 338 MPs 280 were
present a few tweeted out they were
having technical issues and if there are
somewhere remote and they don't have the
broadband or the internet connection
then they're going to they're going to
feel that they're not part of it and I
think that's a problem oh and remember
we said no heckling well the speaker
does have one trick up his sleeve I do
have the ability to mute individual
members I can't want to go there so I'll
just leave it at that new tools adapting
to a new virtual reality abigail diamond
global news Ottawa
what it's like working in long-term care
ahead a first-hand account so many
frontline workers all over the world
have died of kovat 19 including more
than 100 in the UK and so today there
was a moment of silence to honor them in
Quebec a second care worker has died of
complications from Kovac 19 31 year old
Stephanie Tessier was an orderly at a
seniors residence north of Montreal it's
people like her who were on the front
lines they go to work every day knowing
it puts them at risk but doing it
because the people they care for are so
vulnerable Mike Armstrong talked to a
nursing assistant in Montreal about her
hopes and her fears you've come out
during one of your breaks thank you very
much because I'm sure those breaks are
extremely important yes in rare what do
you do when you go back in once I go
back in is to make sure that everybody
is fine to make sure that I take all the
temperature I have a lot of antibiotics
that I have to give intramuscular II and
I have to wrap to dead body when I spoke
to you a few days ago you had almost
forgotten
how many people you'd wrapped preceding
few days me honestly I think I wrapped
already six that's just you know in one
week yeah that's just me in in the whole
Center I heard there is over 30 death
there are thousands and thousands of
health care workers like yourself who
are off the job
how understaffed are you I don't know
maybe 30 to 50 percent on their staff by
example on my floor today I'm the only
one we're supposed to be one nurse and
two nurse assistant and I'm the only one
for how many patients for 29 plus 13 so
about 35 35 resident what does it mean
when you're understaffed like that what
kind of care are the patients get that
means the patients are going to get less
less care we
I'm gonna get less time with every
resident there is think that I won't be
able to do there is medication that I
won't be able to give they won't get
clean pop properly you know they won't
get full wash they we won't give them a
bath we won't change the bed they see it
the resident they start to be to be
scared they they complaining with reason
they don't receive proper care right now
what about when people go home to their
families like yourself you go home to
your daughter everyday yeah I'm I'm not
scared because she's 3 years old and I
there is good possibilities that she she
fights it but yes I'm scared for my
daughter not for me but for my daughter
do you think you had it I think I have
it I think I have it for sure be working
in the redzone working with low stuff
like this everything is everything is
infected we touch everything it's it's
not true that it's safe or I think I
have it
Valerie beret says she wants to be
tested and it's still waiting for that
to happen that is global national for
this Tuesday I'm donor Friesen today is
the 30th national day of mourning in
Canada it's a day to honor those who
have died were injured or fell ill as a
result of their job and it takes on an
even more poignant meaning today as we
honor all the frontline workers in this
pandemic thanks for watching take care
of yourselves bye bye
[Music]